[Music]
all right so like I said I wanted to
welcome everybody and it's good to have
you from various places all over the
world and I'm about to share the screen
there we go so I think we are shared now
and what we're going to be talking about
is the five phases of ethical hacking as
far as I know there will be a recording
of this it's going to be made available
I was a bit late on getting on the link
I think somebody talked about this and
the reason I bring that up is because we
have quite a lot to cover to cover today
and in doing so I don't want you to miss
anything and so so let me make sure
we're getting sound I have one person is
not getting sound just to double-check
with our meeting people are you hearing
me okay Dinesh are you hearing me okay
everyone else just to make sure that
loud and clear about it okay very good
so the person you can't hear probably
just needs to unmute all right so we're
going to talk about is the five phases
of ethical hacking now this is only an
overview this is not the end-all be-all
of hacking and we're going to do an
overview we're going to try to get
through all phases we're going to
demonstrate a lot I want to show you
some of the tools that we have available
for ethical hacking and so and and
Dennis I just want to hear from you real
quick can you see my slides okay so I
want to make sure to have a big KK here
so yeah yesterday we're very good all
right so just double-checking here
normally I have two computers I'll watch
the webinar on one of them and then to
monitor it and then I will do it from
the other but I'm traveling this week
and so I'm out and about and it's not
easy to monitor as it was before let's
talk about this state
of hacking the state of hacking now I
want you to see that this first slide
took place in 2014 so we're starting in
2014 and back in 2014 58% of large
organizations suffered staff they
suffered rose
security breaches 60% of small
businesses you can see over here had a
security breach 81% of larger
organizations had a security breach
59% of respondents to this particular
poll expected there would be more
security incidents in 2015 and guess
what there were in fact by 2016 we could
see over here in the next slide there we
had 1.3 billion records stolen every day
157,000 every hour 2600 every minute and
every second 44 records stolen alright
so this does not even include breaches
in general this is talking about data
records stolen and it goes beyond that
this today we see that Russia India and
other Asian countries are targeted by
Chinese hackers and we see that there's
a Ukrainian hacker detained and Russian
hacker pleads guilty if you look in the
hacker news you see that HP is
installing telemetry on PCs that you buy
so if you have an HP PC you just bought
it might be watching you it might be
watching you Google detects android
spyware that spies on whatsapp so we
have Android spyware spying on whatsapp
we have in Skype calls Mac OS High
Sierra bug yes your Mac is not as safe
as a lot of people claim anyone contain
root access without a password for high
sierra world's biggest botnet just sent
12.5 million emails with the Scarb
ransomware so and these are just the
front pages
some of the hacker news sites out there
and recently Elon Musk who is of SpaceX
you know I love watching SpaceX rockets
and he's just recently come out with a
giant rocket that's going to take people
endure in the world in 30 minutes to me
that that's totally cool but he also
runs Tesla and Elon Musk says that
preventing a fleet-wide hack is their
top security priority in an interview
this year Elon Musk said that let's say
that all of the Tesla cars got hacked
and they all drove to New Jersey and
then they all all the Tesla cars in the
world are now in New Jersey that would
be the end of Tesla so they do a lot to
compartmentalize and to provide users
with ability to cut off any
communication from a servers so that's a
big priority because as things get more
automated and more automated hacking
becomes a big deal so what if hacking
its exploiting vulnerabilities
compromising security a modifying an
application or features to achieve a
goal outside the creator's original
purpose now this is where you get the
idea of hacks life hacks you know use a
newspaper to sweep your porch or
whatever you know something that is not
normally necessarily used for one
purpose can be used for another purpose
and the same thing applies to computers
a but that same skill can be used to
steal pilfer and redistribute
intellectual property leading to
billions and eventually trillions of
dollars in business loss but I like
these definitions a little bit better so
hacking is gaining access wanted or
unwanted viewing copying creating data
leaving a trace without the intention of
destroying data or maliciously
maliciously harming the computer you
know if your friend says hey I can't get
access to this file or this app on my
phone or on my tablet or on my
computer and you say hey let me help you
out with that and you do it you just hat
I've helped many people get into their
Windows 7 yeah you'll see this on the on
the C eh this is all a lot of this is
derived from the ceh courseware but not
all of it I've I've added a lot of my
own stuff to this particular deck and so
the good guys are what we are talking
about when we talk about ethical hacking
right and so the bad guys is what we
call cracking cracking is breaking into
a system without permission it's the
opposite of hacking hacking and hackers
are commonly mistaken to be the bad guys
most of the time crackers are the ones
who screw things over as far as creating
viruses cracks spyware and destroying
data now these three definitions I got
from the internet number one source for
technical definitions yes that's right
the urban dictionary alright so maybe
it's not the number one source but it is
a source and it depends on who you I
don't necessarily recommend going there
but it had some good definitions for
hacking there so a hacker is an
intelligent person with excellent
computer skills they do it as a hobby or
they do it to gain knowledge but there
are others who try to do illegal things
and succeed in doing illegal campaigns
with hacking and that is not what we
train people to do we train people in
ethical hacking ethical hacking involves
the use of tools tricks and techniques
to identify those vulnerabilities
identify the exploits and guess what we
guard against it and make sure that a
unethical hacker cannot break in so to
beat a hacker you need to think like one
it allows you to counter attacks from
from from hackers
so reasons why everyday shinjuku hackers
while to prevent hackers from gaining
access uncover vulnerabilities to
analyze and strengthen the security
posture do you know that it takes on
average how many how many days do you
think it takes on average for an
organization to discover that they have
been breached
post them in chat how many days put it
in chat how many days do you think it
takes an organisation on average to
discover that their organization has
been breached it has been hacked what do
you think well the actual we have some
people say in 30 days
some people say more than that 30 days
right some people say 60 some people say
10 days oh look I have someone saying
it's one year one year and I tell you
what you are closer to the truth three
months right it takes an average of over
about over 200 days so it's about 205
207 days so it's over 200 days on
average before an organization discovers
that they have been breached meaning
that for that entire time that they have
had the hacker in their system running
amuck cracking into files selling things
on and on the darknet etc and so there
are great reasons for us to be able to
detect that remember that 200 days is a
mean and average that means that if you
look at a standard distribution that
there are some organizations that have
had hackers in their organization doing
whatever they want for the last 10 years
and have never noticed and others who
find it in an hour but most it's about
200 days so what ethical hackers are
here to do is find out what we can do to
guard that system with reconnaissance
what we can do to prove that a hacker
has less of a possibility of gaining
access to the system right we have want
to make sure that we protect that data
in the system patch those systems and
also even quantify the time and money
and effort required for the protection
that our organization is looking for and
are there security measures are they
compliance with legal and industry
standards that's what ethical hackers do
now a lot of people when we talk about
hacking and then say hey I'm learning
hacking somebody will say wait a minute
isn't learning hacking isn't that
illegal no it's not illegal think about
this we send our kids to karate right we
want them to learn that if a bully comes
they can defend themselves we go off and
we take kung fu right learn a stance and
we learn to punch we need to block you
know we're not just learning to block
when we're taking karate or kung-fu or
MMA we're learning to punch we're
learning to kick we learn all sorts of
self-defense why not because we want to
attack anybody but because we want to
understand what it is so if you're
walking in the park and somebody comes
up to you and you have great
self-defense skills you turn around put
pull a stance with your fists out and
the person looks like you like wow this
person knows what they're doing I think
I'll go after someone else now that's
the way to be but if you cower in and
fear or don't know what to do well then
you're more of a potential victim and
that is how your company looks when you
don't want when your company looks when
it doesn't have that stance so we want
to give our companies that defensive
posture by training in hacking which is
why we train hackers absolutely that's
what we do to make sure that you have
what is necessary
defend yourself and not be bullied not
be stolen ripped off taken down have
lethal business activity against your
organization rather we tend we train to
hack and the hacking field for us is
going to be a white hat hacker
and there are several different
questions coming in and we're going to
be answering questions mostly at the end
but I will answer one question that I
saw pop up that to me is extremely
important to answer which was how well
does it pay and we're going to get to
the five phases as we go through this
and I will back up in just a moment and
give you the overview and then we will
get back to the five phases but I want
you to know you that this field pays
tremendously well this field is a very
well-paying field and not only that but
it is extremely needed in organizations
and since it's so needed it pays well so
yes one of the things to keep in mind
though as we'll see as we get into some
of the technologies that is going to be
very important to make sure that you
actually have a huge set of skills
before you take that first ce8 class and
either way what you're going to do is
you're going to be learning how to hack
the first type of hacker out there is
called a black hat hacker and and what
that is is a an individual with those
extraordinary computer skills with those
extraordinary computer skills but they
use it for evil a white hat hacker
somebody like you or me that have those
professional skills but we use it as
security consulting I hear a clearing
throat if it someone has a wants to make
a comment go ahead and do it
next is gray hat so this is somebody who
would work and during the day as a
security consultant but at night they
would be hacking suicide hackers and
script kitties and cyber terrorists and
state-sponsored hackers and activists
you can read all these definitions there
are various types of hackers now to
restate the five phases of ethical
hacking the first one is reconnaissance
after that would be scanning and then
after scanning will be gaining access to
reconnaissance
scanning gaining access maintaining
access and then covering your tracks so
RC GMC RC GMC reconnaissance OS r RS GMC
RS GMC reconnaissance scanning gaining
access maintaining access and covering
tracks and we're going to try to get
through some of those today we won't get
to all of them but we'll get through a
few amount a few of them the first one
is reconnaissance remember after that is
scanning after that is gaining access
then maintaining access and then
covering your tracks and the reason I
mention those so many times because
there are some of you are taking notes
want to make sure you have that down so
for reconnaissance this is where we
gather information the firt one of the
first phases of reconnaissance is
dumpster diving I don't know if you've
heard of dumpster diving but people
throw away very interesting things
what might you find in the dumpster of
an organization well one thing you might
find is old passwords right these are
passwords that have been used before
giving us the pattern for passwords and
we have names of people for instance the
names of all the principals so for
instance if I find that the the name of
the system administrator is Tony Montano
right then I could say right on I'm
going to be able to masquerade as Tony
Montana Oh
when I want to get stuff done I can find
out information so I I do that by
passively gaining that information all
right without directly interacting with
the target and then even and the late
phases doing active reconnaissance
making a call to helpdesk technical
department seeing what how things are
run with the organization right so again
if for those of you here are the five
phases again right ethical hacking we
are now in reconnaissance getting that
information finding out what's going on
and then we go from there as a part of
reconnaissance which is foot printing
and I'm sorry I when I had too many
slides there foot printing is the
process of collecting as much data we
want to know their security posture we
want to reduce the focus area if we find
out that there are specific IP addresses
at play here then we can make use of
those IP addresses and and not all the
others for instance rather than having
to scan 65,000 IP addresses if I just
know two or three then that's great our
one domain that makes things much better
identify vulnerabilities I can scan
ports find out which ports are open I
can do banner grabs and find information
on what is behind those ports and how
they're working then draw a network map
and now I know how the entire network
works how it looks
I may even at this time have switches
and routers IP addresses and subnets I
might have a specific security protocols
maybe even dark areas behind which I
have was not able to gain information
and so we want to grab all the
information if you look here we see a
variety of information that we want to
gather from the network to the systems
to the organization's information don't
have time to go through each one of
these like that would in a normal class
but there are quite a lot and some of
the more important ones for instance are
TCP and UDP services that are run
right ACL is that are running if I can
find passwords and systems names and
users and groups if I can get employee
details if I can even go get news
articles and press releases over time
that give me the footprint of that
company so I will go through search
engines using social networks and sites
and website footprinting email who is
DNS you know one of the coolest tools
out there is our search engine from
Wikipedia to Google lots of information
can be extracted about the target just
from going through search engines
through being through Google you can
search a site and for it let's just have
a look at some of the some of what you
can do with a search engine so for
instance um I am going to look at let's
say that there's a director of a company
or a person and then I want to know how
fast they might be able to respond to a
security incident in terms of actually
getting on site and I find that this is
where they're located right so I I can
do a Google search and get a map search
and actually look at you've done this
before haven't you
yeah me too you can look at anyone's
specific house look at that there's a
hacker Shack right there you have the
hacker shack with a hacker trucks no
actually I have no idea whether this is
in Kevin Montana this is one of two
cities in the world that have my first
name Kevin okay now here it is that's
better that's a nice bigger house right
this is the hacker domicile I'm not sure
where it is but either way you can grab
information right
if I have a unemploy of a company and I
want to find out information about them
I can type in information about them put
their name and quotes in Google but you
have to use a quotes because in Google
the quotes mean to use this exactly
right so I put that in quotes and I put
some piece of information about them
like for instance I put in CC and a
as could I know this person has CCNA and
I do this by the way I do this when
we're onboarding employees I can get an
entire public profile of an employee
just by simply doing a search like this
all right and I'm getting some I'm
getting a mic somebody's mic has turned
on and I hear background noise just FYI
and so this gives me if I can see this
guy Kansas City Missouri 10 years a CCNA
NP routing switching et cetera right
then if I wanted to I can type in this
watch I could do Kansas
City Missouri alright now I can localize
my search and get white page entries and
uh find Spokeo information more LinkedIn
profile may have multiple profiles I
don't know right then I can go to
Facebook and find information on the
person right so if I wanted to
impersonate somebody I would have
everything I need to to take that person
and and impersonate them or to even grab
their their their passwords now this has
happened to several political candidates
and what has happened is they they go to
Facebook or some other location and they
are able to find the person's mother's
maiden name their name of their pet
their school where they grew up in and
for grade school or whatever and then
answer the security questions for their
email and then gain access to their
email and then it gets published on line
if you if you heard of that before
political candidates who will get their
email splash online and adapt how they
do it and by the way two things about
that be let's stay on on public in
restrictive websites two things about
that number one the number one thing is
when you answer those security questions
when you set up an account
those are passwords those are passwords
so if your mother's maiden name is I
don't know give me a maiden name uh your
mother's maiden name is let's say my
last name King right so okay
siddhappa alright so if your mother's
maiden name is Sujatha what do you do do
you put that in all of those forms no
you make up a name make up a password
and use that right you don't use that
you use a fake name because this is a
password what was your first pet well as
my first pet named
crackin well that was really my first
pet's name then I will use Vesuvius as
my pet's name all the time whenever I
see a form I use Vesuvius because nobody
will go and look up my facebook profile
my LinkedIn profile my Spokeo profile
and come up with the information because
all the information in there that I use
is completely fallacious it's not true
they're all passwords so don't fall prey
to that and right now in fact I would
suggest coming up with a list of those
names to fill in for those types of
sites keep it remembered though
otherwise you'd be in trouble when you
try to get back into your email
determining operating systems I can find
out what operating system that a
organization is using and decide find
the version of the operating system and
hack it based upon the operating system
I can use Google Maps wiki the the wiki
map Pia and National Geographic and
Yahoo Maps and being maps and get
information on the layout of
organizations buildings locations do
time go back in time on Google Earth I
can go back in time and see how things
have changed again like we're talking
about with people linked in different
services for social media business
social media private social media you
can find out a lot of information about
people from varoma too in Telus the 401
people search public background check
for just $25 you can find out um almost
everything about almost anyone and if
you have the time you can do it free by
going to multiple services and go into
social media etc so with that and
financial services and job sites and
using alerts so that if anything changes
with Yahoo or Google or Giga alert
you'll get a little message that says
that that information has changed from
Google Groups you can get so much
information by
putting together advanced google hacking
techniques like query strings and google
operators that one thing i will show you
is of the google operator this is one of
my favorite ways of foot printing and
getting information about sites and so
on so let's just jump on into here we'll
go back to there right and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to find out
information on the command prompt but I
am going to put it in the site site
colon Microsoft com right and so now if
you look at every single hit every
single hit is from Microsoft com
so I'm searching from within there now
if I want I can even this gives me how
many hits empty I have four hundred
ninety seven thousand results but now
I'm going to look for that specific
phrase by using quotes alright now I
have or an eighty five thousand hits and
I can find that in microsoft.com and
only in Microsoft comm so if I wanted to
let's go into a new site let's go into
cisco.com and we'll search for that you
see I have sixteen thousand four hundred
results about the command prompt and
Cisco comm every one of these references
comes from that site right so if I
wanted to search in a specific company
for a specific string I can use Google
advanced search operators I I suggest
looking into these and trying them you
saw how I used it I would suggest
learning to use that and again social
networking sites from Twitter Pinterest
Google+ you can look up any user anybody
in a company and find out information on
of these sites what the users do what
the organization does what the and the
attacker gets that information website
footprinting is easy to find you go to
the specific website and you can dump
information one of my favorite tools
along that vein is called Firebug make a
note of that it's a plug-in that you can
use for Firefox and Google Chrome that
allows you to grab all kinds of detailed
information about what is in that site
but there are many other tools like
Informer that will allow you to do the
same thing you can't examine cookies on
sites which can lead to impersonation
cookie snarfing and others you can
actually take the entire site and
mirrored it have you ever mirrored a
website have you ever downloaded an
entire site to give me some chat if you
have downloaded an entire site and then
maybe taking it with you somewhere yeah
me too I've done that for it allows you
to take your time and examine that site
and others have used things like that to
impersonate those sites so it's not a
good thing to be able to have your site
so easily cloned but it's also more
difficult because anytime you go to a
website you are actually downloading
that site that page excuse me to your
local computer you're downloading it
actually printing a black widow page
Nesta and the new widget and teleport
pro yeah there are a lot of very good
tools out there to copy that content
some of them are free some of you have
to pay for but yeah you can clone those
websites and okay give me give me some
chat how many of you yes or no have you
gone to the wayback machine yes or no
everybody have you gone to the wayback
machine if you haven't gone to the
wayback machine i suggest going to the
wayback machine and for instance I would
do that today but we were really low on
time
is look at Microsoft site for instance
Microsoft comm and you go down to let's
say 2000 or 1996 for Microsoft calm as
you see here and you'll see the super
old yeah for Facebook or others you find
the site I've seen old sites that I have
had way back in the past no longer have
that are still archived in there and you
can use that to gain information about
companies that you use for footprinting
purposes monitoring websites using
website watcher and then we get to the
next level of ethical hacking which is
scanning but before we do that let me
show you one of the tools that we use to
learn ethical hacking and this is an
epic Oh hacking lab I'm going to resume
it here and here's one of the questions
I have for you if you want to practice
hacking and you download a series of
hacking tools what is one of the
problems with that well number one your
antivirus software will go crazy and it
will try to delete those tools number
two you might get fired from your
company for having hacking tools right
number three you might get arrested for
trying out your skills on a on an
unsuspecting company so it's much better
to be able to actually have your own lab
now there are many different ways to
create your own labs using
virtualization but when we teach
certified ethical hacking we use a lab
that looks like this and so it guides
you along so that you can login for
instance I'm going to go ahead and hit
the ctrl alt delete' and i'm going to
paste in the password and login right
here right and and then I have Server
2012 r2 I want you to see something else
to check it out over here machines I
have a Windows Server 2012
Oh eight windows 8 one when the seven
Kali Linux Ubuntu an Android machine I
have NAT set up to do some routing some
lots of stuff to hack and it's a guided
exercise I'm going to go ahead and close
server manager here and then you'll see
here what we're going to do next is
we're going to launch this Firefox
browser and and then there is a website
that has been created for us to hack and
this one is called or to it we're not
really hacking it we're just doing foot
printing right now so we go into dub dub
dub movie scope alright calm and there
it is well not quite there it is right
so this is a site that lives in this
environment only and we can use it to
find information about this site alright
so if I go over here to the navigation
toolbar here and I go to Firebug and
there it is and here I can get
information about the CSS layout of the
site actually before I do that let me go
over here and just look at some of the
the actual setup of the site right if
there are if there's any bad coding for
this site we'll be able to pull out some
of that just by looking into the each of
the sections of the site so I can look
at the margins the padding the borders I
click the outline look at the layout of
the site alright I can go to the style
sheets and look at those alright go here
to the console I'm going to enable
Firebug but either way what I would do
is I would be able to find information
now in fact what I can do which is
really cool is I can log into the site
as you notice it's not using HTTPS
therefore I'll be able to capture the
login into the
site using Firebug right there's are
more exercises than using the web
extractor in using a network analyzer
right so for instance here we have to
install path analyzer Pro and I want to
show you something here before we go
into the install which I probably won't
have time to do because we're running
out of time already but what I am going
to do is I'm going to go over here I
want to show you something here this is
what I call a treasure trove in these
labs and only in these labs we have a
really cool folder called ceh tools
check it out watch this and watch the
ticket and open it up and wha the angels
are singing look at that footprinting
every constant scanning network you
numeration system hacking malware
threats sniffing social engineering
session hijacking sequel injection a
Goan sequel injection and i find a blind
and detection and injection tools and so
on so we go into any one of these tools
will find various ways of doing this
here's email tracking tools underneath
reconnaissance from email trackerpro
which is one of the ones that is really
nice I can install it if I want and so
within the offices of these labs there
are literally scores of tools that we
learn about and learn to use and then
guess what you take this with you to
your company and you are able then to
use them to secure your company against
people who are using using them against
you all right so um so I'm going to give
you just a brief look into scanning and
then we'll have to to pipe down here
because we're running out of time
hacking takes time takes a lot of time
to hack the five phases of ethical
hacking that we see here on the left are
not based upon the hacker
these are based upon what it's from the
perspective of the hacker I guess that's
what you're saying from the perspective
of the hacker and from the perspective
of me the white hat hacker the security
consultant what I'm going to do to test
the network of my whoever I'm working
for is these and that is what a black
hat hacker and attacker someone's trying
to crack into my network would also use
these against me so both I use these to
help test my network and an attacker
uses this to help to try to breach my
network okay so this is just a path that
you have to go through in order to gain
access to resources in a network so and
depending on what information you
already have you will do some or none or
not there's never never none some or
maybe a slightly different order you
might do it like for instance if you do
a quick scan and you realize oh wow
there is a very quick way to get in here
I might just gain access right away and
then get what I'm looking for and not
maintain my access just get out of there
and I may not even clear my tracks uh
why well because I have what I want and
I'm I'm pretty anonymized on the way in
or I might delete logs on the way out so
yes these can be used very flexibly and
as you will see there are so many
different tools that can be used from
sniffing to port scanning to Mac
flooding DHCP attacks to using your
switches and routers and sniffing in
various different ways
this is one of the places where I wanted
to get before we end today to let you
know that hacking requires a great
understanding of what a packet is what
are the layers of any operating system
and network application transport
presentation etc the OSI model and
that's one of the things
we teach also in your places of work you
might get to use protocol analyzers some
of these things like these a fluke
meters etc are extremely expensive
devices that you see only the most
professional security professionals use
and large organizations you can use
wiretapping you can use many different
ways of doing things in fact the NSA one
of the biggest I would argue the biggest
wiretapper packet grabber and hacker on
the face of this small planet and in
fact some of their tools for doing just
that have been stolen we've had major
data breaches with the NSA themselves by
just one on scrupulous in scrupulous
person all right so from scanning we
have a gaining access which we don't
really have time to go into where you
use various tools to gain access and
from gaining access we go through all
the other phases maintaining that access
and then a clearing tracks and with
clearing tracks that is extremely
important for both the security
professional to understand how that
works so we can look for signs of that
and then not just a security
professional but the hacker is trying to
clear their tracks by deleting disabling
auditing getting rid of log files
closing ports etc now there was a time
when people did not understand why we
would train in hacking in ethical
hacking because it seemed like an
oxymoron I think we all know now that
that is not an oxymoron because in order
to be able to protect your systems you
have to understand
how those types of attacks work IOT um
quantum computing AI ubiquitous
computing networks desktops phones
tablets and devices that you cannot even
imagine are coming and you are one of
the first lines to guard against them
being attacked and subverted so that is
why we train hackers now I would suggest
everyone in this webinar get hacker
training so that you can learn to defend
your devices and your networks and for
the sake of time I think that's all we
have for today
all right do we have our moderators
sorry about that I have to find my
beautiful seven so button because you're
so busy opening up panels and looking at
different questions going by yes
hopefully because we did start about
five minutes late so I'm hoping we can
go just a little bit over okay just one
of the questions it always comes in and
I've already seen a couple hidden back
there if someone is starting their
career out and they I mean most people
start our careers outcome online going
way back when like you I'm also from
Albuquerque area so I went oh yeah but
whether things you know we kind of throw
a dart at the board and say well where
do I start well that looks cool let's
let's learn hacking okay I've got a
little skill in it what would you
suggest were these people who are just
starting out their career for
certification and education and
experience to get in and dive in to this
particular domain
well the the biggest way to the place to
start there there are two areas that are
important in hacking and one of them is
well that just makes make it three
there's networking
there's computing and there's
programming those are the three legs
that we stand on so when I talk about
networking we need to be able to define
the answer to the question what is a
network what is a network how does a
network work how does it function Oh
think about it this way and somebody
who's in the hacker field in a computer
security field needs to have a
fundamental understanding of what
happens when they click on an item in a
website now what I mean by that I mean
that when I click on that item in the
website how does that get turned into a
packet how does that packet get put on
the wire how does that packet get
through my wireless or my wired
connection how is it handled at the
wireless router how is it handled at the
switch how is it transmitted from the
wireless router to a physical router and
then how is that routed from one network
to another and then how does it that
packet flow on the network how is it
treated from router to router knowing
that networking is extremely important
now the next thing is computing in
general what's a CPU house memory what's
difference between RAM and ROM and how
do clock cycles work at the CPU what are
you know what's a PID those types of
things in a computer are important and
then lastly and it's more important when
you get to the upper levels of computer
security but programming because once I
get a very good tool I might want to
write a script for that tool or I might
want to create my own script so where do
you start
you start with something like one of our
our classes that train in basic core
elements of computing if not you can do
a CCNA or something like that or even an
M CSE from or something like that would
be very helpful for gaining those basic
networking skills and then you can move
into hacking already having understood
in fact if you if you have a if you have
a CCNA really you are that you are
hackers it just hasn't started using the
tools yet so so you have to get into
basic networking understanding and gain
facility with using and working your way
through networks so something like that
excellent I'm going to make just a quick
note for those people who had some
questions on like we get back to some
other information or the screen or that
screen these sessions are recorded so if
you want to request a copy of the
recording you can go to simply learn
calm and just let let me to the chat
window come up let them know you were
here and they'll send you a link for
that yes and I will also post the slides
on a I have a I have a presentation site
and so if I get emails passed on to me
from you guys from any one of you if you
pass on the email to me I'll give a link
to that site for slides okay excellent
we will have to talk to the Beckett
simply learn like yeah I'm also remoted
in yes
and that's I we have if we can still one
more question this is I think one of
those weird questions that I see a lot
artificial intelligence how do you see
that as being both a good or bad aspect
specific to since we're talking about
hacking in the hacking industry and how
that would sex it okay that's an
extremely important question first of
all I'm going to just do a quick
definition of what artificial
intelligence is and artificial
intelligence is the ability to mimic
what a human does
using a computer basically that's what
it is
now most AI that we have these days and
for the very near-term foreseeable
future are going to be specifically
targeted AI so for instance you might
have an AI
right now we have Watson and Watson is
great at reading books or reading
websites and providing information like
to doctors or playing on if you look up
Watson and look up jeopardy you'll see
watching that can actually play jeopardy
too right but if you say hey Watson how
you feeling today Watson will have no
idea what you're talking about
it's not a general-purpose AI so for the
foreseeable future
AIS will be targeted in a specific field
or task and they'll be very good and
very fast at it because they'll be able
to do a processes that take a human days
years or weeks in milliseconds and so
what will happen eventually what I
foresee is that there are going to be
hack a eyes I've never heard this talked
about but there will be hack a eyes
these are a eyes that are built
specifically to hack so that for
instance I can say hey AI here's an IP
address attack it and it would do
everything I would do over a period of
five months it could do it in a day
right and then return the results to me
how do you guard against something like
a hack AI well in the exact same way
that you guard from any other advanced
hacker and that's what you learn in
these types of classes and then the next
thing I just want to say very quickly
two more things you also will have
defense AIS and so knowing how to
configure and how to configure yourself
for your defense posture on a computer
system will help you be able to work
with defense ai's in the future so
you'll find you'll buy devices or
subscribe to services that are
artificially intelligent
sleep on a is is the AI that Elon Musk
talks about Bill Gates talks about and
others is the general purpose AI which
will be coming your way within the next
thirty years
maybe twenty years depending on Ray
Kurzweil and others the general purpose
AI will be a human level general
intelligence just like each one of you
are a human level general intelligence
but it'll run a trillion times faster
than you can run and it will also be
able to duplicate itself and that's when
we're in big trouble
but you don't have to worry about that
yet because we don't have one coming for
a while and meanwhile it is important
for us to understand all of the aspects
of computing and computer security so
that we can guard against and make use
of a is in the near term and long term
future we're not worried yet but we're
getting there yes very good summary yes
one more quick question on any time yeah
I played eight times short one where was
it in the ce8 getting the certification
and going through that are you people
going to be required to do scripting or
no scripting and if so what language or
what sort of would they want to be a
little knowledgeable in in the ceh we do
all our programming in binary I'm just
kidding no no it's eeh even though it
requires a fair amount of knowledge to
do well in the ce8 what we do is we show
you tools that you're going to be using
to guard against and and understand
attacks and so on so no you will not
need to know scripting before getting
your ceh is mainly networking and
computer knowledge
so yeah so no worries about that oh
there we go I'm still in muted okay okay
yeah excellent that's true yeah that's
always important to know what you're
getting into when you're diving into a
new class whether you have scripting or
no scripting needed yeah
certainly my I come from the programming
side so certainly my experience is that
any scripting you have as you go forward
will have aspects that spill into you
know you'll be able to combine them
later on as you very clear fill up your
skills yeah any programming or scripting
that you have is always valuable and it
will give you a leg up and and I just
want to make a quick comment too because
I've seen a lot of questions I'm
actually pacing back and forth and I
periodically glance at the screen here
I've seen a hard as the exam how it
difficult is it to to do the exam it is
not an easy exam let's put it that way
and so it's very important for you to
have a very good handle on the major
tools and techniques of ethical hacking
in order to do the exam like for
instance that lab I was just showing you
if you're if you're able to that's why
we provide these labs so that students
will be able to practice practice
practice all of the techniques in all of
the labs that we teach you should learn
enough to be able to do them without
being directed so for instance if I told
you to use nmap for a specific purpose
that you'd be able to to do it if I told
you to use a meterpreter shell to find
this information you would be able to
use a meterpreter shell if I told you to
ask an the network and find this
particular information or what if I told
you to craft a packet what tool would
you use and how would you do it what is
packet crafting so those are the types
of things that you would learn in Aceh
class and by doing that hand
on is of extreme importance
excellent I think that puts us a little
bit over which is great we just start a
little late again a reminder to
everybody that you can go to simply
learn calm and if you go into the
support and send a note or talk to the
chat window they can send you more
information and a lot of times they go
through these questions and also send
out emails if we miss something yeah
definitely learn is is great so I would
I would definitely suggest that
excellent and also if you have questions
for Kevin here they can forward them to
them so let them know on there also yes
with that we'll go ahead and close a
webinar I want to thank everybody for
being here again Kevin thank you very
much for your time we appreciate it I
did I always have fun with these I
learned so much they're fun and on old
dog learning new tricks that's why I
always perfect and then you know we have
the niche in the back so thank him for
joining us also I don't know if he's
still over there I care it was an
absolute pleasure I think this was a
very informative session the only
challenge with us doing an article
acting overview sessions all this time
because such a wide and vast topic and
it's very difficult to crunch
information but we will have resources
circulating to the attendees and anyone
who wants no more to simply learn
whether it's recordings of webinars
whether it's white papers whether it's
video resources there's a plethora of
resources that ISA Gungan simply learned
collaboration has put together for
people who want to know more information
about some of the questions that I saw
was like what are the courses they can
offer before ceh how difficult is the
exam how the exam based off practical or
or or cure articles all those those epic
use are going to be available through
simply learns landing page or and or any
resources any questions that you guys
have that's not there always feel free
to reach out to simply learn and compare
anything else we'll make sure they get
addressed I just want to put it out
there excellent thank you great
excellent and look forward to see you
guys in our classrooms
happy learning and a good evening or
morning afternoon depending on where
you're at and everybody have a great day
[Music]